[Musique]
bon alors les amis euh j'espère que vous
m'entendez j'ai je vais avoir une minute
de décalage avec vous donc je vais avoir
besoin de de votre retour dans une
petite minute
je vais un peu augmenter le le son de
mon micro visuellement ça
fonctionne bon c'était pas le bon micro
par contre c'était pas le bon
micro mais j'étais en train de regarder
en même temps les Chiquet qui s'est pas
ouvert on va on va faire ça
bien fait les joueurs sont pas encore
encore arrivé donc c'est pour ça je suis
en train moi aussi de de prendre les
informations
ah les chiquier les chiquier les
chiquier il y a
00 là c'est
mvl avec les Blancs la zavic avec les
noirs
mais attendez faut que j'aille chercher
un
truc alors est-ce qu'on a tout bien je
crois qu'on a tout bon on a plus qu'à
attendre que ça
commence on a bien la Davi c'est bien le
siège de mvl on a bien la bonne partie
c'est bien en 41 c'est bien la division
1 c'est bien le premier à 2 et
demi on est
parfait un tout petit peu de retard mais
je crois qu'en fait c'est 17h le début
de de la 3e division ou je sais pas ce
qu'ils font avec les divisions mais
c'est pas étonnant que ça commence à
17h05
si firou Carlsen et nepis l'homme le
plus heureux au monde nous ditons dans
le chat alors moi je suis pour grand
supporter de Martinez Alcantara bien
bien évidemment le joueur péruvien en
espérant qu'il aille au
bout ça va pas être facile il y a
quelques joueurs en
embûche en tout cas laav est
concentré il y a pas mal d'argent en jeu
hein
évidemment je regarde en fait si vous
voyez regarder l'autre écran c'est que
je regarde ce qui ou là j'ai oublié de
mettre mes lunettes en
plus pour ça que je suis obligé de
m'approcher autant de l'écran plus
l'habitude de mal voir j'ai reperdu
l'habitude bon c'est loin d'avoir
commencé encore
hein
maisavic quouis c'est un petit il a 17
ans et il a beaucoup de
médailles
et il a énormément de
médailles quel cadence c'est du 10 +
2 donc c'est une belle cadence ça va
vite quatre parties ça devrait être
torcher en 3 He maximum on aura le temps
de voir France Irlande ce
soir
et ça enchaîne pas mal hein je pense que
c'est à mon avis dans
2h dans 2h on est plus là à mon avis
hein ça va être Bam Bam Bam Bam et après
il y aura peut-être un Armagedon donc ça
peut durer 2h30 mais à mon avis c'est
2h30 3h max hein
c'est c'est vraiment du Bam Bam Bam
Bam quelque part tant mieux qu'il a un
peu un peu de retard c'est toujours un
petit peu plus de temps alors qu'on a
Maxime qui arrive avec la tisane le
machin
bah moi aussi je vais aller faire la
tisane après entre les partie si
c'est si c'est la prépa des
patrons
si c'est ça la prépa des patrons
mesdames et messieurs on va prendre
note petite bouteille
d'eau tout est là pour
Maxime
Maxime qui a l'air bien en forme qui est
bien
prêt ah il a l'air d'être facile
Maxime
en tout cas il s'est mis s mis
bueno ala aussi à la bouffe et fait Doss
vous voyez pas moi j'ai j'ai fait dos
aussi sur les
cam d'être dans une chambre d'hôtel
al il a l'air très tranquille
aussi c'est qui en face en face de
Maxime c'est c'est Denis lazavi un
joueur qu'on voit très peu en réel mais
qui a fait un bon championnat du monde
de Blitz
rapide qui avait pas pas mal joué
lorsqu'il avait joué les final à
Toronto joueur
béorusse mais Maxim moi il est chez lui
euh tranquille
hein il exhibe il exib pas son lit
je j'ai pas plus d'information que vous
en réalité actuellement ça va peut-être
commencer à 17h15 je vais regarder sur
le live officiel parfois ça me permet
de d'avoir des petites
infos donc laavi qui a éliminé
ikarunamura hier faut-il le
rappeler ce qui est quand même un
résultat
retentissant
alors attendez je vais jeter un œil sur
le live est-ce qu'il y a une au moins
une information de de temps à vous
donner pour avoir au minimum une
information de
temps attendez je me tape la pub de
chesscom
évidemment
non ils sont ils sont sur les cames en
plein
écran mais pas
d'info il sont sur la cam de la zavic en
4K
bon on grattera pas d'info sur sur le
début en tout cas ils sont plus en
plateau hein pour pour commenter
l'événement ils sont depuis chez
eux les coupes budgétaires sont
réelles surtout 2-0 c'est leur pour Naka
ouais mais on a bien moi j'ai analysé
hein la partie ce matin sur ma chaîne
sur ma chaîne facile la défaite
d'ikarou je pense que ça va bientôt
partir Maxime
concentré
bon on par le Réap des premers jours
vite fait bah là en fait c'est le
premier réel jour hein le reste c'était
c'était de la
calife là en gros c'est le le premier
jour de de compétition à proprement
parler
Naka peut mononter la compis loser
bracket non non Naka est complètement
éliminé il est en division 2 tu remontes
pas voilà là on a on a les les matchs tu
ne remonteras pas là c'est c'est ça la
division 1 ikarou en
D2 donc ça ça non voirarou revenir
gagner ce tournoi
non
ce n'est pas possible il ne sera pas
présent je pense que ça va commencer à
17h15 d'après mes savants
calculs
c'est quoi ce tournoi c'est le chessable
Masters
2024 faut pas faut pas que je me fasse
piéger aussi he par le début je vais
quand même
vérifier il y a un monde où je me fais
piéger en fait
la D c'est pas non la D c'est la deè
division JP étant le Main Event oui oui
bon enfin on s'attend à victoire facile
de de
jospem jospem bah oui
je
heureusement
heureusement qu'il y a du j spem
j'espère que vous nous laisserez kiffer
la vibes avec
lui c'est à quelle heure le match d'alza
Alireza c'est en même temps mais comme
je l'avais dit hier on suivra plutôt
Maxime sur ce tournoi dans le sens où on
a beaucoup suivi al av qui on suivra
beaucoup Alireza au candidat et on va
suivre alirea encore au
960 joue beaucoup plus de tournois que
Maxime en ce début de saison donc on va
suivre Maxime là et on suivra après on
suivra bien évidemment les parties
d'alira aussi mais on va on va rester
sur les parties de Maxime en premier
temps et il y a beaucoup de s à la clé
ouais il y a 300000 dollars de de
prix les joueurs se sont barrés
ouais tournoi qui dure 5 jours donc
c'est quand même pas mal 300000 balles
en 5
jours
il y a un petit 30000 au vainqueur de
celui-là et la zavi il a quel âge il a
17 18
ans
c'est toujours pas
parti on sait pas
pourquoi compliqué compliqué là ce début
de de
compétition
tout le monde
attend nous attendons
aussi allez maxime est de
retour je pense que ça va commencer
là
j'avais dit 17h15 mais je pense ça va
partir Maxime il a l'air très facile
aujourd'hui je le connais mon Maxime il
a l'air bien là il a l'air
bien il a l'air très très
bien al je sais pas ce truc d'alerte qui
est un peu
bizarre
il est quelle heure chez lazavic il doit
être 2h de plus il do être
19h20 il a les Noirs Maxime bah je sais
pas là sur sur le truc a les blanc à la
première mais comme je disais he on peut
on peut se faire
piéger moi plus on attend plus ça
m'arrange hein donc au bout d'un
moment
moi si ça dure comme ça jusqu'à 20h
c'est tout bnef hein c'est tout
BF Maxime qui
s'alimente
et qui repart et qui
revient
a peut-être repartir on attend quoi ben
on attend que on attend qu'il joue hein
qu'est-ce que tu veux qu'on attende de
plus
allez ça part alors c'est bien Maxime
qui a les blancs E45 cavalier F3
cavalier C6 fou B5 l'esagnol cavalier F6
D3 donc
antiberlinoise ça peut ressembler à des
italiennes c'est le répertoire qu'a
décidé Maxime pour
aujourd'hui donc vous voyez un 10
minutes plus 2 secondes par coup vous
avez la cadence des 5 et BD2 tout ça est
théorique on va voir qui est le mieux
préparé à ce à ce combat donc on échange
ici on voit dame 7
souvent
H3 pour prendre les cases du Fou est
possible et pour prendre la case G4 au
cavalier aussi dame C2
dame2 B4 prise d'espace le four par en
D6 et là il va peut-être jouer avec A3
pour jouer pour fou B2
C4 c'est possible peut aussi jouer fou
B2 directement mais bon le fou pourrait
aussi aller en G5 donc c'est
moins moins
sû il joue à 3 c'est le coup un peu
flexible ça prépare
C4 prendre de l'espace protéger le pion
B donc A5 immédiatement il le remet sous
pression mais le coup A5 ça a un défaut
c'est que ça ne contrôle plus la ce B5
donc Maxime peut jouer tour à1 tour B1
même tout
court et surion prend on pourra hésiter
entre entre a prend ou c pr pour ouvrir
le fou C1 et éventuellement aller vers
la case B2 tour D8 joué par
lazavic tour
1 F6 dame
C2 ça va être une partie de fond de
cours les blancs qui vont
essayer d'avancer lentement mais
sûrement lazavic qui en
réflexion sur cavalier A7 le fou va
simplement repartir en F1 donc il met le
fou en
E6 dame C2
ouais pas facile en fait les Noirs là
ils ont plus de coup utile c'est ça le
problème c'est ça la
difficulté il y a le cavalier C6 il est
vraiment pris je pense que il est là le
problème de la position si on essaie de
de la comprendre pièce par pièce le
cavalier C6 il
est il aimerait bien re sur une autre
case
quoi peut-être qu'il va même jouer
cavalier B8 un moment pour revenir en D7
mais ça
donnera le temps au
blanc d'avancer avec C4 C5
éventuellement C4 c'est pas le coup
jouer hein c'est moi là qui est qui est
cliqué il a joué H6 donc il contrôle un
peu les
cases mais là Maxime qui aimerait bien
justement jouer C4 C5 mais c'est pas
possible par qu'il y a le pion B4 en
l'air donc il fait cavalier F cavalier
B1 cavalier F1 pardon sur tour A2 il va
vouloir jouer fou
B2
et
ouais malav doit doit trouver des coups
quoi Maxim est en place il veut petit à
petit venir vers3 taper sur les cases F5
D5 il fait cavalier H5 il veut améliorer
ce cavalier l'amener jusqu'à la case F4
après à savoir qu'on aura toujours dur
G3
là je m'attends à cavalier E3 il va
commencer à toucher deux belles cases
avec ce
cavalier et toujours ce cavalier C6 un
peu un peu bloqué il a du mal
à à se remettre en place Maxim qui joue
G3 directement il laisse pas le cavalier
rentrer ça a l'air bien
joué ça a l'air bien joué ce
G3 ça vient prendre la case tout
simplement au cavalier
F4 don qui met la tour en à2 la zavic
tour B2 bon fou B2 était possible aussi
mais tour B2 c'est mieux au moins on va
pas avoir de problème de
clouage on échange et comme ça quand on
joue C4 le fou intervient immédiatement
sur le pion E5 Maxim est bien dans son
match pour le
moment commence gentiment il joue vite
blzavic aussi vous voyez que la barre
d'évaluation de l'ordinateur affiche
égal mais j'ai l'impression que Maxime
est quand même un petit peu dominant
pour le moment il met une petite
pression à la pendule ça c'est
gentil et puis il a une position plus
agréable c'est clairement la zavi qui
est légèrement sous pression lui qui a
éliminé he ikarun camura hier al ce
n'était qu'une demi surprise he bien
évidemment mais quand
même il
a bloqué la route au streamers
américains vers cette première
division donc cavalier F6 cavalier E3 et
je pense qu'il va finir par jouer
cavalier B8 C6 et cavalier D7 ouais un
coup typique je vous ai dit he ce
cavalier qui était pris dans les pions
et un jour ou l'autre il allait revenir
sur ses
pas Maxime concentré mais son
adversaire joue de manière extrêmement
solide ça va être difficile là de de
faire la différence pour
mvl laavi a réussi à serrer les
dents
peut-être que Maxime va devoir jouer
avec fou
C4 pouritchanger les fous et
potentiellement revenir vers les cases
D5 ou
F5 ah oui on pourrait faire une akadame
en D2 cavalier D2 2e
division pourquoi ntait-ce qu'une
demiurpriseélimination d'ikaro par
lazavic Ben lazavic sur ce format de jeu
il sembla être top 10 mondial il a l'an
dernier participé au final du champion
chestour il se qualifie encore cette
année ikarou est peut-être je comprends
pourquoi l'ordinateur met un point
d'interrogation cavalier H4 c'est
logique on a vu le cavalier E3 qui
tapait sur F5 il en ramène un deuxième
euh on a vu la zavia qui dans dans ce
format là typiquement semblea être top
10 top 15 mondial et ikarou qui est pas
en super forme depuis un moment
euh donc c'est c'est qu'à moitié
étonnant de de voir lazavic
l'éliminer
donc cavalier H4 jouer il veut aller sur
la case F5 les blancs qui sont un peu
mieux l'ordinateur qui raconte un peu
n'importe
quoi comme
souvent et l'arrivée du cavalier en F5
pourrait faire mal donc il fait G6 alors
est-ce que ça peut un petit peu
affaiblir le pion H6 je comprends pas
les les annotations de l'ordinateur là
ne ne vous fier absolument pas je pense
qu'il raconte n'importe
quoi mais ouais maxime a pas accès à la
case F5 et il a du mal à taper sur le
pion
H6 est-ce qu'il peut jouer C4 laisser
fou prend B4 et prendre en
E5 fait fou F1 je pense qu'il veut à un
moment donné jouer C4 mais fou prend B4
pour le moment ça tap la tour
en1
C6 mais ouais c'est solide on narrive
pas à avancer peut-être mettre la tour
en
D1 menacer C4 mais il fera peut-être B
D7
simplement attention pour Maxime de pas
trop
s'obstiner
dans une position un peu de fond de
cours ne pas forcer au point de se
retrouver
mal bon aprèse façon la position elle
est là il faut bien la
jouer est revenu en F3 il a fait son son
travail d'affaiblissement des cases
noires autour du roi j'imagine que les
Noirs vont jouer cavalier BD7 ici et
peut-être qu'il peut tenter tour à
Maxime pour tenter de le long de la
colonne ça peut être une idée de
décalage pourquoi
pas et c'est joué par
Maxime et c'est jouer la tour qui va
débarquer de A1 pour aller jusqu'en A7
au coup d'après
essayer d'exercer toujours cette
minuscule pression microscopique
il réussi à conserver maintenant depuis
une petite dizaine de
coups par nous
gratifie une magnifique coupe de cheveux
que l'on peut vraiment observer de près
j'ai envie de
dire dame
E8 al je suppose qu'il veut tour A7 tour
A8 tour B7 dame
C8
c'est
solide c'est extrêmement solide
ouais les pièces noires qui font front
face face à l'attaque blanche on narrive
pas à
passer je vois pas comment Maxime peut
progresser à partir de là il va encore
nous trouver une manière
probablement il fait F4 il décide
d'changer une
pièce tenter d'un petit peu aérer la
position et se gagner les cases avec
avec son
cavalier 423 pour laav 539 pour Maxime
s'il peut réussir à mettre son
adversaire mal
autant il aura peut-être après un
shot
en tout cas lazavig pour le moment
suffisamment
précis allez il descend dessous des 4
minutes de
Nice il va probablement échanger les
fous en tout cas tolérer l'échange
peut-être par un coup
comme8
est une possibilité
clairement des positions de fond de
cours après la maxime est en train
de de réaliser ce qui peut réaliser pour
gagner cette partie c'està-dire prendre
un petit avantage au
temps et même si c'est que 2 minutes ça
va pouvoir suffire si la position reste
compliquée pendant encore une 10
quinzaine de
coups
à pousser l'adversaire à faire une
imprécision et
après augmenter sa
pression en tout cas là il va passer
sous les 3 minutes là Davic allez là ça
commence à devenir
intéressant il joue B5 il essaie de
prendre un peu le taureau mvel par les
cornes mais Maxime va revenir je pense
en F1 avec son fou non il échange et il
fait tour à 6 il va jouer tour à 6
ici sur cavalier B8 il ira se glisser à
mon avis en A8
tour à 6
jouer cavalier B8 il va mettre la tour
en A8
maintenant Maxime qui est en
train de prendre un petit quelque chose
il y a un clouage sur le cavalier Maxime
qui va vouloir jouer C4
maintenant et taper sur le pion
E5 cavalier BD7 cavalier fd7 pardon donc
il veut renforcer la protection du pion
E5 pour limiter la force d'un coup comme
C4 Maxime qui peut maintenant jouer pour
H4 avec l'idée de faire H5 pour se
donner la case F5 et sur H4 H5
peut-être amamener ce cavalier sur la
case G5 et utiliser ce petit
trou pas sûr que soit si utile que ça au
final il joue fou C ouis j'adore le coup
fou C1 il va pas réussir à jouer C4
c'est bien défendu donc il décale le fou
il veut aller viser maintenant le le
pion H6 cavalier B6 attaquer la tour la
tour qui est revenue en
A7 cette tour c'est difficile de s'en
débarrasser complètement
et la zavi a plus que 2 minutes
20 à mon avis il va jouer Roy G2 Maxime
puis H3 cavalier G4 c'est
joué il montre petit à
petit ro G2
H3 cavalier
G4 sont les trois prochains coups en il
a commencé déjà par ro Roy G2 les deux
prochains et la zavi qui passe sous les
2 minutes mais c'est vraiment la
stratégie de Maxime il joue une position
sans risque mais il joue vite et il
réussit de par sa vista et de par son
niveau de
jeu à mettre une petite pression
combinée sur les chiquers et sur la
pendule est-ce que ça va suffire rien n
est moins sûr et maintenant il joue C4
un coup à gauche à coup à droite alors
sur foupran j'imagine qu'il veut p prend
puis on prend dame C8 et dame prend
à8 si les Noirs prennent en C4 il va
reprendre du cavalier
j'imagine il peut même prendre de la
dame dame prend cavalier prend prise 5
prise prise à 5 prise5 en tout cas il
complique encore la position 3 minutes
d'avance maintenant pour Maxime on va
passer sous la minute 30 pour la zavic
et Maxime qui met qui met qui met la
pression qu'il augmente avec chacun de
ses coups il force à prendre des
décisions qui sont pas simple et là la
zavic va bientôt se retrouver avec une
minute il va se retrouver dans l'urgence
donc il a repris du
cavalier le fou qui est reparti en en
F8 est-ce que Maxime va repasser le fou
en B2 ouais sur fou prend B4 en fait il
y avait aussi fou prend H6 hein qui
était qui était une
possibilité peut-être Maxime maintenant
va revenir avec le fou en B2 maintenant
que le fou F8 a couvert le pion H6
Maxime qui réfléchit qui fait des
mouvements
carroanesques il a raison he c'est c'est
à ça que ça sert d'avoir de l'argent de
l'avance a temp j'allais dire de
l'argent au temp mais oui le temps c'est
de l'argent
aussi il en a plus que la zavi qui
mainant il revient en B2 comme prévu
Maxime qui fait le chicchac Lordi qui
dit que c'est une faute mais en réalité
c'est un coup très logique allez réussir
à mettre la pression sur la zavi à la
pendule il fait F6 il est solide le
joueur bélorusse d'ailleurs est-ce qu'on
dit bélorusse ou
Bélarus quoi qu' quoi qu'il en soit il
est très solide hein il c'est il a
avancé tous ses pions d'une case son roi
est légèrement affaibli mais on narrive
pas à en profiter pour le moment côté
français plus 3 minutes 28 pour
Maxime et il faut réussir à créer un
accident allez cavalier à 5 ça provoque
C5 il va peut-être jouer pour B5
maintenant
essayer de remettre le cavalier en C4 et
et permettre d'avancer encore et
toujours plus que 3 minutes à présent
pour
Maxime allez il prend C5 il va reprendre
du cavalier je suppose même si le Fou
est aussi
possible allez il arrive à la minute la
zavic il arrive sous la minute c'est
dans ce territoire là qu'on voulait le
voir il reprend du
cavalier est-ce que Maxime va tenter fou
à3 pour échanger le fou et après jouer
contre ce roi un tout petit peu
affaibli
désolé ça donne soif de voir c'est
parti en C5 F à3 cavalier rebouge F
prend F8 ça peut être une option quand
même et Maxime doit penser que ça
suffira
pas il y a cert ce petit affaiblissement
qu'il a obtenu mais ça manque de tour
pour pouvoir en profiter
il joue FO à3 ouais c'est logique mais
là on imagine cavalier D7 F prend F
cavalier
prend après à savoir est-ce que si
Maxime réussit à ramener un cavalier
vers D5 qui peut encore avoir une chance
peut-être surtout qu'il reste plus 40
secondes maintenant pour la
zavic allez c'est comme ça qu'on veut la
gagner cette partie depuis le début
cavalier à 6 un coup relativement
étonnant je trouve cétait la première
ligne de l'ordinateur pensit pas que ce
serait joué et ça a l'air plutôt bien
joué Maxime qui joue cavalier H4 ces
cavaliers qui ont des
rebons
étonnamment
ah il manque de pièces là pour Maxime il
manque une
pièce il manquerait une paire de Tours
pour à mon avis pouvoir
vraiment mettre la
pression
dame B1 et peut-être un coup
ici s'éloigner pour essayer de rentrer
sur une belle case plus
tardou est gagnant apparemment dans sa
partie Maxime qui encore une 36 contre
secondes il a plus aucune pièce sur l'
dame on aimerait bien réussir à jouer F4
ou quoi dans de bonnes conditions mais
F4 je pense qu' a pu on prend puis on
prend et la dame qui pourrait venir en
G4 cavalier C4 et jouer donc il veut
revenir vers E3 ah il va jouer cavalier
E3 quasiment à tempo ici attention hein
parfois il peut y avoir des cavaliers F5
échec qui peuvent fonctionner ça a pas
l'air d'être le cas là le cavalier qui
revient en
E8 lazavi qui fait les bordures cavalier
D5
ah il veut peut-être F4 puis on prend F4
qui prend
G6 c'est empêché ah il peut peut-être
faire F4 quand quand même puis on prend
F4 cavalier prend F4 G5 cavalier F5 F4
paraît intéressant à moins que je ne
rate quelque
chose peut-être qu'il peut juste ne rien
faire mais il joue F4 ilre pr il
peut-être F5 on sait pas
trop cavalier
C7 Maxime qui va revenir en E3 je
suppose avec le cheval non il fait dame
C6 c'est bien joué sur cavalier prend il
veut e Pr et obtenir le pion passé
lazavic plus que 15
secondes Maxime sur pion prend est-ce
qui
compreprendreoui cavalier F3 roi G3 il
sera safe il va faire cavalier F3 dame 2
roi G3 non il fait dame C2 peut-être
très bien joué il tape sur le pion G6
maintenant F5 pour lazavic allez Maxime
il faut réussir à avancer le pion
cavalier
F3 CAV lazavi qui fait cavalier F6 il
tape sur le pion
D5 dame B2 effectue un clouage mais il y
a peut-être dame B7
attention Maxime qui se retrouve mal
maintenant tout d'un coup laav qui fait
une partie absolument
gigantesque c'est beau ce qu' fait
Denise lazav il a défendu pendant 30
coup face à
Maxime pour finalement trouver le le
petit avantage ici Maxim qui va devoir
cravacher maintenant pour faire
nul ça va pas être
simple il devrait y
arriver mais ça va pas être facile
lazavi qui a sorti une partie absolument
magistrale c'est pas du du Maxime de
mauvaise facture ici mais c'est du très
très grand lazavic qui confirme tout le
bien qu'on pense de lui hein il est
vraiment très fort dans ces tournois il
a éliminé ikarou il a éliminé tersaan
hier il a l'an dernier il s'est qualifié
pour les phases finales très souvent
placé lui qui dans dans ce format est
prob probablement top 10 voire même top
5 mondial attention quand même cette
année on a aussi peut-être Martinez
Alcantara qui paraît en grande forme en
train de battre le vicechampion du monde
y nepashi on a la affaire à des
spécialistes de ces
formats ils sont extrêmement forts et là
la zavi est en train de nous prouver une
nouvelle fois pourquoi il mériter sa
place lors des finales de l'année
dernière il a vraiment commis aucune
erreur dans cette il a été parfait
intransigeent niveau de jeu qui pourrait
en faire peut-être
un un prétendant au au candidat de de
2026 il joue vraiment très bien allez
cavalier
E5 allez Maxime qui va réussir à la
tenir une partie vraiment de haute
volé
cavalier F7 ça y est il a forcé le coup
H5 ça a l'air plutôt d'être une bonne
nouvelle ça va pas être facile à tenir
ça faut surtout pas perdre là avec les
Blancs Maxime qui fait un beau
travail
va faire cavalier H8 cavalier F7 non
pour marquer une victoire de jospem
contre
nepomashi mon
chouchou dans ce tournoi qui
s'impose c'est bien
Maxime ah il veut voir est-ce que la
finale est nulle la finale a l'air nulle
prend 6 ro D4 3 D6 ro
C4 ouais elle est
nulle bien joué de la part de mvl
précis il calcule roi B5 ro5 ro C4 ro F6
roi D4 il peut pas passer sur G5 a FG F4
et le roi qui
revient et Maxime qui se tient dans une
partie de de haute volée allez ça c'est
un bon un bon premier
résultat on va essayer de voir ce qui se
passe du côté d'alireza firouja Alireza
qui
a les pièces noires pour le coup non
c'est dans l'autre
sens je sais pas pourquoi on a 10 là
qui qui est làza qui a les noirs
le pion qui a une ce de dame désolé on
n' pas les bons noms mais bon vous avez
compris le
système vous avez compris le le
système et Aliza qui
s'impose avec les noirs on a vu qu'il
était qu'il était
gagnant bien joué à
lui bon donc ça ça va faire 1-0 pour
Alireza on va mettre à jour le score de
Maxime c'est
0 on va mettre à jour les scores donc
c'est 05
05 faut que je mette un tout petit peu
la scène à
jour euh parce que là on a player m
one donc là on est Maxime avec les Noirs
donc on va faire ça comme
ça
hop et hop
ça c'est
bien
donc ou on va confirmer quand
même pour ses supporters la victoire de
de Martinez Alcantara et il a bien gagné
oh là là là là là là quelle partie il
avait les pièces noires Martinez
Alcantara il a donné une leçon à Yan
pomashi la
les
ouais il a
complètement défoncé
ouais il a été
exceptionnel attends
attendez
ah donc ça ça doit
être
attendez
hein jeis JIS à faire une petite
manipe
je fais une petite
ok bon comme ça on a nos on a tous nos
trucs prêts pour pour la
suite
oh c'est déjà reparti côté Maxime ou là
c'est c'est reparti hyper vite
désolé ça allit extrêmement vite comme
ça jouis pas de l'autre côté pas eu le
le temps de voir donc il a eu D4
cavalier F6 C4 G6
G3 G2 D5 donc c'est la zavic avec avec
les pièces
blanches et Maxime avec les noirs on va
se mettre dans cet ordre
là au moins on garde on se garde côté
Maxime et donc il a jouer B3 un coup que
j'avais jamais vu je crois enfin
c'est ça transpose
dans une dans un genre de
grenfeld mais les Noirs sortent bien de
l'ouverture dans le chat tarde un peu la
finale j SP laavic ouais si si lazavic
réussit à aller au bout là il va tomber
sur un
os on va voir si jospem réussit à à
continuer sur ce
niveau
tour un
jouet tour C1 donc estce qu'il va jouer
A6 Maxime pour prendre la case B5 rien n
moins sûr il peut jouer cavalier C6
aussi
il joue à 6 il vient prendre la la case
B5 on va voir on va voir position solide
pour le moment pour les Noirs meilleure
structure de pion mais les blancs un
petit avantage de
développement B TR ultra théorique ouais
ben je sais pas après comme je suis
passé vite sur la partie des fois je
suis un
peu je suis un peu
perdu à vrai dire j'avais la tête encore
au changement donc c'est possible que
B3 en tout cas ils ont joué vite c'est
moi qui est sûr m dit n'importe quoi les
amis soyez
indulgents je m'attendais pas à ce que
ça reprenne de manière aussi
instantanée
donc à 6 à 6 jouer prend le contrôle de
B5 il prépare cavalier C6 pour pour
pouvoir pour éviter qu'
B5 vous voyez que l'ordinateur préfère
légèrement les blancs mais franchement
moi je suis
pas je suis pas
catastrophé
c'est pas le genre de position qui
m'inquiète généralement mais j'aime bien
avoir des avantages à long terme comme
comme cet avantage structurel après si
l'ordinateur avantage envisage que
l'avantage est pour les blancs c'est
sûrement qu'il a raison cependant c'est
pas une turbine très forte donc que
profondeur 22 ça pas dire grandchose ça
peut vraiment bien se tromper dans un
sens comme dans
l'autre donc à voir
à voir à
voir je pense qu'il va jouer cavalier C6
maintenant Maxime alors d dit qu'on peut
jouer avec Dame B3 après mettre la
pression sur ce pion B7 qui se retrouve
arrièer un peu comme les pions
isolés dès qu'on avance on l' fatigué
Maxime à la cam avec C4 qui C4 il va
jouer à case B6 ah je sais pas s'il est
fatigué mais son adversaire vient de lui
jouer une super partie dans la dans la
première et là il continue à a
jouer a très bien joué
apparemment
parce que moi j'aurais eu en tête
cavalier prend des4 fou prendre des4 et
fou C6 mais apparemment fou E5 dame C8
et cavalier à 5 est vraiment
fort en gros moi je me serais retrouvé à
100 % dans ce type de position là et en
grand danger avec les
Noirs mais j'aurais absolument pas senti
à ce moment-là le le danger j'aurais pas
compris que les blancs sont mieux ici
moi personnellement j'aurais échangé et
et fou C6 et je me serais fait dominer
lentement mais
sûrement mais Maxime lu il comprend la
nature du
danger
bon on va voir comment il
continue on va voir comment il
continue il prend des4 et fou C6 sil
joue comme j'aurais joué il fait fou C6
leur dit qu'il recommande lui plutôt fou
B5 fou 5 c'est pas bête ça tape un peu
sur sur eu deux et ça
bloque il joue fou E6 mais le dit a pas
à cause de dame
B2
beau
B dame B2 qui pose vraiment problème et
oui parce qu'il prend la grosse priorité
sur la diagonale il va avoir priorité
sur la
colonne regardez hein dame B2 c'est fort
en fait ce qui est important de voir
c'est la géométrie regardez le fou G2
qui tape sur B7 avec la dame et le fou
B4 qui tape en G7 avec la dame et donc
la dame en fait c'est le dénominateur
commun des deux fous elle permet de
taper et en B7 et en G7 c'est vraiment
très joli
en fait le placement de pièce est
vraiment très beau après dame
B2 donc il joue
3 qui fait 3 bon il a raté ça va
permettre à Maxime de faire fou des5
dans de meilleures
conditions 3 c'est fort quand même ça
vient ça vient là aussi consolider le
fou il y a le problème en en
B7 donc je pens F des5
sur tour B8 il y a fou E5 donc ça on
peut pas tour D7 il y a cavalier E5 je
suppose ah cavalier5 il y a pas encore
mais on se met dans du cavalier
E5 donc fou des 5 ouais non fou des5
vraiment
logique puis en plus on est plutôt
content d'échanger ce fou du fionketo
quand même on a du mal à attaquer le roi
pour le moment mais qui sa un jour h 5
H4 H3 ça peut toujours
arriver joue dame B6 la zavic voà ça va
liquider un prise cavalier prend fou
prend et cavalier quelque part je pense
qu'on va tout liquider et faire nul ici
côté côté
français on est obligé de commencer par
dame prend B6 puisque dame n'est pas
protégé on peut pas jouer F pr G2
à moins que Maxime soit gourmand il joue
dame
C8 en se disant que sur F prend des5 il
reprend du Caval il regagne un temps sur
la dame c'est gourmand non il prend B6
c'est plus logique peut-être c'est pr f
prend G2 prise G2 et cavalier quelque
part ça va échanger les fous il doit
vouloir jouer sur le pion B6 mais j'y
crois pas trop côté
laavic
toute façon reprendre la dame il est
vraiment obligé donc il hésite entre
cavalier prend et puis on
prend cavalier prend c'est vraiment pour
faire nul en fait parce qu'on va
échanger et on jouerait C6 après puis on
prend c'est plus
ambitieux on veut essayer de gagner le
le pion B7 en force plus tard dans la
partie il a peut-être l'idée assez
malveillante sur foupr ropron d'aller
jouer cavalier à 5 tour C7 donc Maxime
va devoir couper cours à toutes ses
véléités il y a un léger
danger il faut rester vigilant et c'est
pour ça que Maxime prend vraiment son
temps
ici donc il prend les cavalier
E4
il a eu raison là
Maxime très
vigilant très très
vigilant il a pris son temps au bon
moment pour éviter tout problème
irrémédiable sur le sur le pion B7 et là
le cavalier4 qui est qui est VI il peut
revenir en D6 la tour peut venir en
D5 F prend roi prend faut juste pas se
prendre une tour en C7 dans le mauvais
tempo
mais en gros là cavalier à 5 il faut
bien jouer ouais l'ordi donne comme cou
plus précis tour D6 c'est tour D6 c'est
vraiment bien
joué parce que si la tour part en B1 on
a quand même bien limité l'activité
surtout qu'il y a peut-être cavalier D2
qui gagne ah ouais donc S a même pas
tour B1 c'est tour D6 cavalier B7 tour
B6 et peut-être même que c'est la tour
de Maxime qui rentre en premier en B2
Maxime va pas être mieux mais mais les
Blancs ne contestent absolument plus
rien dans cette
partie mais ce cavalier quand même
malveillant à
5 heureusement que Maxime fait le taf
précisément ouais ça y est là il s'étire
il sait qu'il a fait le plus dur allez
Maxime faut pas se déconcentrer
il y a encore un ou deux coups précis à
jouer et allez pour toi mon garçon la
partie
nulle et le petit un partout là qui nous
tend les
bras 350 pour Maxime il joue tour des
deux wou il rentre dans l'agressivité
gratuite
Maxime alors il laisse B7 en l'air il
veut quoi sur prend B7 il veut tour
prend
A2 cavalier C5 on bouffe bouffe et tour
B2 t C6 t B8 bon on va réussir à faire
nul comme ça aussi c'est la partie
d'ailleurs mais sur tour C7 il veut tour
B2 il découpe il découpe le pion sur
place ah il veut tour B1 tour B8 enferme
le cavalier ah il a il a quand même
glissé un petit piège ici il est content
il est fier de lui Maxime
il est fier de lui la malveillance est
maximale côté
mvl on l'a senti quand il a fait les
étirements qu'il avait vu quelque
chose et là il a ce petit
chipo mais sur tour C4 il a cavalier des
deux ouais il en a il en a posé
quelquesunes de petites pet de banane
qui vont tout être vu he par lazavic
mais ses pots de banane permettent à
Maxime de s'en sortir et tour C7 qui est
peut-être le coup le plus dangereux
alors aveid sur tour B2 tour prend E7
pour contre-attaquer le cavalier il veut
peut-être un coup comme roi C7 qui sait
roi F6 pardon et
E6 350 pour les deux hommes la zavic
devrait pas pouvoir en offrir plus en
demander plus dans cette
partie cavalier C5 voilà ça c'est la
simplification totale de la part partie
du jeu d'échec tour B8 tour à1 tour
prend B6 tour prend A6 et les deux
hommes vont se quitter bons
amis Maxime qui veut quand même tenter
de garder son pion à 6 en vie peut-être
mais bon ça ça va être difficile Maxime
quand
même connaissant lousti qui regarde à 5
ça c'est un coup de lousti tour à 1 tour
à 8 peut-être mais bon c'est un peu trop
un coup de loustique il fait à 5 ah je
le connais comme les doigts de ma main
mais je sais qu'il regarde ça tour
à8 mais le problème du loustick c'est
qu'après tour à8 tour tour à 4 on pourra
jamais non c'est bien joué côté lousti
allez il fait tour des8 il veut te
reprendre à 5 tour des de ah le loustick
n'a pas envie de laisser de
demi-point ah là là il est insupportable
ce mvl allez peut-être il faut faire
tour C4 tour D2 tour F4 mais il veut
encore E5 tour F3 E4 tour F4 G5
peut-être ou F5
G5 Maxime qui dérange là dans cette
finale allez tour CC1
il va faire tour D5 je le connais mon
loustick je connais mon loustick là
c'est tour des 5 c'est sûr la mass
veillance c'est toujours maximal
ou tour ah tour d 6 non c'est tour D2
tour F1 et tour D5
maintenant ça a l'air assez malveillant
comme manière de jouer ah mais il a
peut-être tour
B1 ah non il en peut il peut pas en
faire plus là il a fait une petite
grimace tour D5 tour
B1 t prend B1 t tour prend B1 t prend B1
donc il peut pas et tour B5 t prend B2 t
prend B2 t prend a 5 t prend
B6 la malveillance cétait maximum côté
mvl mais tour B5 ouais il est toujours
aussi malveillant mais maintenant tour
B1 ah il veut tour F5 la malveillance et
maximal ah mais il y aurait peut-être
B7 et perpétuel
seulement mais il fait pas de cadeau
Maxime il ne fait pas de
cadeaux jamais au grand
jamais
il est
insupportable il est absolument
insupportable
Maxime P7 de
laavic il va réussir à échanger quand
même en
force Maxime qui propose nul et c'est
accepté la malveillance de mvl n'a pas
suffi laav qui sen
tire à bon compte et donc ça fait un et
demi et
demi
les deux hommes qui ont fait une bonne
partie on va aller voir côté firou al
avec les pièces
blanches qui a une
position
exceptionnelle égalité matérielle non un
pion de plus pour F C mais regardez
cette dame qui brille sur la grande
diagonale on va regarder d'où ça vient
c'était une
carocane ça a pris un pion rapidement
côté fedo CF
ouais c'était peut-être pas si mal la
position mais c'est peut-être en train
de s'écrouler plus que de 23 là si al la
gagne ça fait 2-0 et ce serait ce serait
terminé il trouve C4 cavalier B4 il va
envoyer le cavalier en G5
ouais regardez la dame à 2 regardez le
cavalier B 4 ils sont aux
abois ils sont aux abois le cavalier qui
va arriver en G5 il y a plus de case
blanche côté fedo CF alors que l'ordi
propose tour A1 dame B3 tour A3 dame C2
avant d'envoyer l'attaque peut-être
aussi et cette tour qui pourrait
naviguer sur la 3è rangée ça forcément
alirea y
réfléchit en tout cas alirezak une une
belle position
ici gagner ça ferait
2-0 il aurait besoin plus d'un
demi-point sur les deux dernières
parties pour se
qualifier au tour
suivant il réfléchit pour le moment
Ali F CF
aussi il a plus de temps mais quand même
de 47 c'est plus que
13 il sait qu'il est en grand danger ici
Fed CF mais bon tant qu' on trouve pas
de mat direct on peut pas être sûr de
gagner c'est sûr qu'il regarde du
cavalier G5 H6 cavalier E4 mais il y a
pas de mat à proprement parler on sent
que les blancs sont gagnants on comprend
la barre d'évaluation quand on est en
partie on le sait aussi que ça doit
gagner mais il faut trouver les coups
précis cavalier G5 ici il va peut-être
jouer Damas 5 et sur h et sur damage 4
H5 est-ce que G4 suffit à gagner j'en
sais rien
ok G5 c'est le c'est le coup
logique et H6 cavalie
4 on pourra pas éviter cavalier F6 ouais
donc ça semble vraiment difficile he le
C8 qui est complètement spectateur de la
partie ici pour fedo
CF 59 secondes pour
Alireza 1 minute 51 pour fedo CF il y a
les 2 secondes de rajout par coup là le
coup cavalier E4 il est extrêmement
facile et pas tant que ça alerza qui
réfléchit quand même il doit réfléchir à
caler tour 1 avant ou
pas alors là c'est encore une gaffe
l'ordi donne gagnant après cavalier F6
ro G7 doit pas être possible à cause de
cavalier H5 et mat donc ro H8 forcé
maintenant l'ordi veut faire dame D2
menace dame H6 roi G7 et cavalier G4 il
a joué dame H4 alirea qui pour moi est
plus logique cavalier G4
maintenant on n'est pas loin de mat H5
dame F6 ro H7
je comprends qu'il soit rentré là-dedans
mais quand bien même l'ordi ne kiffe pas
trop parce que on aimerait bien qu'aler
après un tour à1 tour A3 tour H3 mais on
a peut-être pas le temps donc là H5
c'est la logique même dame F6 ro
H7 c'est forcé et là il se trouve qu'on
a pas de
gain de manière relativement incroyable
je
on a l'impression qu'un tour C3 ou un
tour un tour à 3 fait la différence mais
c'est pas le cas et plus 4 secondes pour
Alire Reza ah c'est terrible
il avait l'impression que c'était
complètement
gagnant et finalement c'est pas le cas
il laisse le cavalier en prise et il va
jouer H3 pour s'ouvrir la colonne h
après puis on prend et peut-être qu'il
fera tour3 à ce moment-l oh vous allez
voir ça va être fort il y aura peut-être
E5 pour tout défendre ah il veut H3 puis
on prend et tour 4 plutôt oh c'est malin
c'est malin ça pour alirea là il va y
avoir H3 vous allez voir non il fait fou
pr G6 et dame prend F8 dame dame prend
B2 et il y a plus de gain
c'est passé à côté pour Alireza qui va
se faire
égaliser incroyable la position était
complètement
gagnante mais il réussit pas à terminer
et c'est fedoseev qui va qui va
s'imposer probablement dans cette
parti il est obligé d'échanger les dames
ala il met la tour en D8
mais il a encore une toute petite
défense sur B5 F B7 encore tour
D7 il va falloir trouver des idées là
pour pour s'en sortir il met le pion en
C5 il veut complètement fermer son
adversaire cavalier C6 tour8 mais
attention ça peut sortir via 5 à 4 à 3 à
2 à il va falloir mettre encore de tris
barbelet pour pour
alirea
cavalier C6 tour8 on veut absolument
garder et maintenir le problème oh mais
maintenant la tour peut plus
revenir donc il tente d'attaquer de
l'autre côté
is mais la tour est bloquée en
E8 il va devoir s'incliner il peut plus
arrêter le pion il tente t PR6 mais A3
tour1 A2 tour A1 cavalier B4 et tour E2
et il y aura pas encore cavalier C2 donc
F qui transforme la
et qui maintenant va jouer cavalier D4
cavalier C2 à 3 à 2 à Dame c'est son
plan il a un petit peu activé le roi il
a aussi le plan d'aller chercher le pion
le pion C5 c'est très
efficace qui tente le contreje avec les
pions H4 et
F4 il faut tenter quelque chose tour à 7
il veut prendre le pion B7 revenir oh
c'est pas mal ce qu'il veut faire et
tenter peut-être de sacrifier la tour en
dernier ressort allez le pion il est
pris la tour on va la remettre en
A7 le cavalier qui revient le roi qui va
venir défendre sur les
pions est-ce que il y a un monde où
Alireza réussi à gagner à troquer en
tout cas G6 contre F4 et après essayer
de dommage hein s'il y avait plus les
pions menacerait déjà tour prend B3 il
tenté de faire nul alors là
malheureusement on a que tour B4
apparemment mais il y a pas
d'échec pour le moment il y a pas
d'échec
donc les blancs s'accrochent la tour4 ça
a l'air
forcé à cavalier D1 roi D2 A3 a l'air de
faire
mal la tour qui va essayer de repartir
de l'autre côté il met deux échec ah
mais il y a peut-être fou C4 et sur roi
prend D1 A2 et on narrête plus le
pion et Alireza qui
abandonne terrible égalisation de F CF
alza qui était gagnant mais c'était
tellement difficile à
trouver il fallait trouver ici dame E3
roi G7
non c'était dur et maintenant dame C3 E5
cavalier H5 c'est introuvable ça et
tourin ah il fallait multiplier les
menaces sur le roi et sur la dame
enfermée
c'était extrêmement
dur parce que si on faisait dam C3
direct en fait il y avait juste
d'amassin qui ouais c'était vraiment
très très dur ce qu'il y avait à trouver
alira qui a l'air d'être dégoûté il a
chercher dans la mauvaise direction et
ça fait un partout dans les deux matchs
je pense que ça va être le moment pour
nous de prendre une petite pause aussi
et on se retrouve à mon avis dans dans 5
petites minutes à tout de suite les
amis quel est le meilleur moyen de
suivre n'importe quel événement échikien
tupat du monde au tournois des candidats
en passant par le speed chess ou les
title Tuesday
chess.com/events Courouvre tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec il se déroule en
présentiel ou en ligne vivez et
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les table base retrouver
toutes les infos essentielles comme le
programme les horaires des rondes les
prix les résultats les contte rendus
quotidien les bios des joueurs les
règles des partag et plus encore vous
pouvez même participer à la compétition
en pronostiquant les résultats pour
tenter de gagner des abonnements premium
alors rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chess.com/events aussi bien sur le site
internet que sur nos applications iOS et
Android pour VI votre passion comme
nulle par
[Musique]
ailleurs
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
les amis je pense que ça va bientôt
reprendre j'ai pas j'ai pas d'horaire
officiel mais je vois les les joueurs se
mettre petit à petit en place donc
évidemment on est on est de retour ça va
pas commencer tout de suite tout de
suite donc on va rester un peu chill
aussi de notre côté mais voilà j'ai pas
envie de de rater la moindre
miette de ce tournoi donc on se on se
remet en
place je pense ça va commencer dans les
dans les 5 minutes à venir à mon avis
18h30
à mon avis
Maxime qui est là en
place la zavic
aussi les deux hommes sont
là
sur l'autre caméra on a lirea qui est
qui est de retour
aussi donc ça va là ça va reprendre ça
va
reprendre pour moi 18h30 ils aiment bien
commencer normalement quand même
à à 30 35 40 à un
conton donc ça veut dire que ça va
relancer les parties à 30 ça veut pas
forcément dire que ça de Maxime va
reprendre à 30 ça peut être 31 ça peut
être 32 mais mais je pense que les les
quarts de finale reprennent à
30 dommage he pour alirea qui
avait la partie en
main et j'en profite aussi he pour vous
dire que ce soir on va voir on a le le
tournoi sur le club blit
stream si vous souhaitez jouer le
tournoi d'entraînement à
21h pour ceux qui aiment pas le rugby
j'ai envie de dire tour du vendredi
21h pouvez jouer aussi en regardant le
rugby en même temps allez ça
repart on a bien fait de de revenir un
petit peu en
avance et donc ça rejoue berlinoise et
Maxime cette fois qui joue qui joue la
finale qui connaî si bien à mon avis il
a pu réviser entre les parties
Maxime 8 fou
F4 bon courage Denis pour pour
celle-là demande si nouvelles du match
JP NEP pour le moment josp 1 et demi un
demi je sais qu'il a beaucoup de de
supporters ici de de la communauté blit
Stream qui sont des des grands fans de
rose Martinez Alcantara et donc pour le
moment la bonne nouvelle c'est qu'il est
en train de dominer
ypashi après la mauvaise nouvelle c'est
qu'en cas de qualification de
Maxime ça va être à Maxime d'aller
éventuellement chercher ce Jos spem gros
adversaire mais donc sur fou E6 cavalier
E4 fou E7 et tour à D1 à mon
avis il veut tour D8 c'est ça échanger
la tour et repartir de l'autre côté avec
le roi
alors peut-être H3 pour préparer
G4 il joue
G4 directement mais alors cavalier H4
c'est 100% sur le coup cavalier prend H4
fou prend H4 c'est sûr H3 H5 c'est
sûr et à ce moment-là d'après l'ordi il
a roi G2 parce que sur pion prend pion
prend fou prend
on aurait quoi un tour àin à la
fin roi D7 et tour D1
échec ro C8 et fou
G3 je suis pas sûr les amis mais
j'imagine que c'est l'idée j'imagine que
ça a été
analysé donc H5 ro G2 HG HG F prend tour
clou roi D7 d clou parce que sur7 a T
prend H4 pr H4 fou G5 donc D7 déclou
peut-être cavalier C5 échec C8 forcé fou
G3 ça doit être la variante et c'est
joli et c'est joli donc il fait fou
7 et là Maxime va pouvoir jouer cavalier
G3 pour gagner le contrôle de la case H5
puis fou3 F4 F5 allez là Maxim est en
train de se mettre en
place
alors que je vois dans le chat
énormément de de fans de jospem
notamment un certain St
83 qui nous a écrit un all jospem et qui
a dû être modéré
par par le bot de ce canal de chat et
oui la fou est enthousiaste de voir son
joueur
favori aussi bien performé dans ce
tournoi
donc la tour rient en D1 Maxime qui
contrôle toutes les cases le long de la
colonne D ça va probablement être
contesté immédiatement par par la
zavic il joue H5 et maintenant on va
devoir jouer avec F3
ouais
solide il y avait F3 dans l'autre
variante d'ailleurs aussi hein au cas
où on est très solide sur
Agag donc tour D8 c'est l'idée dont on
avait parlé tout à l'heure il veut
échanger les tours pour quelque part
régler son problème de déconnexion de la
8e
rangée
et là donc
peut-être peut-être juste 3 G2 pour
tranquillement améliorer la position
côté Maxime non il fait B3 ah B3 c'est
pas mal aussi ça contrôle un peu les
cases
blanches et comme toujours cette
structure le truc c'est que si les
blancs mettent le pion à F5 c'est un
avantage allez on va pas dire décisif
mais très important et donc on est en
train de petit à petit mettre en place
nos
pièces pour y arriver maintenant on va
mettre le cavalier en G3 F5 c'est
peut-être une faute hein c'est la fausse
bonne idée il fait
tour1 alors dommage leur dit qu'i fait
cavalier
G3 on peut comprendre parce qu'en fait
ça forçait à prendre une décision et ça
retouchait la case F5 mais tour 1 c'est
pas mal parce qu'en fait fou prend E4
tour prend D8 3 prend D8 tour prend E4
leur dit à beau dire que c'est égal
c'est pas du tout égal quand tu joues
parce qu'en réalité les blancs vont
rester avec la bonne structure et donc
ils vont pouvoir valoriser leur pion je
vous montre hein pour schématiser mais
ça c'est pas du tout égal l'ordi dit 0
évidemment enfin c'est égal pour
l'ordinateur parce qu'il peut jouer
parfaitement mais à vrai dire quand on
voit disons cette position c'est pas
égal juste regardez par
vous-même non évidemment il va pouvoir
faire ça et bon là il aurait pas fait
tour des deux mais voyez là on va on va
finalement avoir un avantage avec les
Blancs c'est pas égal ces trucs
là
qu'on sent dans le chat une certaine
malveillance un certain Théodore Conrad
très très
malveillant aïe aïe aïe aïe aïe tel un
spectateur malveillant du Tour de France
qui ne croit pas dans les performances
des
champions on connaît beaucoup
ça qui ne s'extasie pas devant les
exploits de
certains il tient toute la
responsabilité bien évidemment de de ces
propos qui sont avonsle très
limite donc ro
D7 m si le roi en G2 le fou en G3 le
pion en F4 ça paraît
bien donc c j'ai2
6 tour des4 moi j'aime bien les blancs
je dis l'ordinateur si vous mettez la la
barre il affiche 00 mais bon fou G3 F4 3
F3
F5 mais bon il va jouer G5 il va bloquer
les pions et ça va juste être nul c'est
bien joué ouais en réalité il connaît le
plan évidemment là c'est pas c'est pas
si dur il sait
faire B5 Maxime qui va jouer fou G3 je
suppose et là il va y avoir G5 qui va
être bien joué qui va empêcher la
création des des pions
passés liés
ensemble
ouais et la G5 ça a l'air
fort c'est le coup clé c'est la clé G5
de la position noire mais c'est un coup
logique la difficulté c'était de
comprendre en amont et Maxime qui va pas
pouvoir progresser
ici
très très bien
joué Maxime qui pourra pas presser la
zavi est trop bien préparé trop
fort trop solide Maxime qui va jouer
tour D1 je pense pour préparer F4 puis
on prend puis on prend ro F3 et
contrôler toute la colonne
h
d la Davi est très PL la Dav qui est
globalement très pleutre ouais il joue
tout ce qui est variante d'échange de la
slave et tous ces trucs
là il a vraiment bien joué
parce que Maxime dans cette finale il
est très
dangereux il a réussi à le sécher sans
trop aès maxime a raté une petite
occasion donc on imagine un tour D1 roi
F3 roi E4 G5 tour G1 et G6 ça c'est le
monde idéal mais les Noirs vont pas
laisser
faire
ouais ça va en fait
c'est c'est bien défendu la tour D1 je
pense parce que ro F3 ça va laisser
pénétrer la tour par derrière et tu veux
pas te faire prendre par derrière
tour des
TR al pour rassurer hein Théodor
Conrad son ami jospem hein dont beaucoup
sont supporter ici quand même il vient
un petit peu porter la discord annoncer
que c'était sa dernière année d'échec il
arrête après
donc délecte-toi de ces parties tant
qu'il joue
encore délecte-toi de ce joueur
magnifique qui va peut-être aujourd'hui
éliminer une première fois en tout cas
Yan nepomashi vice-champion du monde en
titre donc tour D3 il veut revenir vers
tour
H3 peut-être il va venir et là je pense
que la zavi a intérêt
à est-ce que Maxime veut tour H3 4 prend
des3 et CD
peut-être c'est peut-être malin mais je
crois qu'il peut pas
progresser en fait il est bloqué quand
même sur case
blanche
ouais il
crée une incertitude mais il pourra pas
passer super bien
défendu il prend du roi il va revenir en
E4 mais il pourra pas passer en
G6 il a l'équivalent d'un pion de plus
he par qu'il va pouvoir faire a 4 C4
mais il peut pas passer son
pion
très très bien défendu franchement c'est
une
superbe superbe défense dans la finale
berlinoise de la part de
lazavic Maxime tu dois regarder fou G5
ah peut-être tu peux faire fou G5 fou G7
tu peux faire croire que tu as fou F6 ah
il veut fou G7 ah non fou G7 fou B4 il
l'a pas
mais il veut peut-être fou G7 fou C3 fou
F8 fou A5 ouais il veut
ça c'est
malin c'est très malin mais c'est un peu
trop téléphoné
j'imagine donc il veut essayer de
s'améliorer le truc et peut-être l'avoir
dans meilleur
condition
[Musique]
HM est-ce qu'on peut tenter fou G5 ah
fou F8 fou D8 3 D7 et on a pas le temps
de faire ro
F5 alors il y a un plan marrant c'est
fou E7 A5 fou B4 fou B6 est-ce que ça
peut passer un truc pareil non puis on
prend puis on prend roi D7 parce qu'en
fait l'idée serait mettre le fou en B6
et les pions A5 C5 mais ça suffirait pas
là il va faire fou d
ouais peut pas passer nul nul pour
Maxime belle partie mais il a pas pu
faire plus trois parties trois
nuls fedf firouja on va aller voir ce
qui se
passe du côté d'alire Reza qui a les
pièces noires ici fou4 échec W ça vient
d'où cette partie encore complètement
folle ça vient d'une Rui
Lopez variante de malade
mental variante de fou
furieux mais malheureusement il va
prendre un échec en E1
Alireza pas sûr qu'il s'incline pas
Ali il a une petite mine quand même
hein envie de lu dire tuas une petite
mine
Ali
il a une petite mine de ouf
non dame
C4
tour 1 roi
F8 il va pouvoir après remettre sa tour
en jeu mais c'est vrai que sa tour en H8
elle joue pas trop mal
alirea la position est très
chaude
la position est tellement compliquée
ouais F dame D2 H4 peut-être ça me fait
un peu peur en fait là connexion des
tours
ouais il a pas une super mine Ali
ouais après il joue bien
mais la partie précédente lui a
peut-être fait mal au au moral parce
qu'il avait vraiment la win en
poche ça fait de jours he qui pe cravage
quand même pour se qualifier
alira dame D2 il va prendre C5 je
suppose
ouais je sais pas c'est chaud tour à1 il
y a un pion de plus mais il y a une
déconnexion des pièces côté noir dur à
dire ce qu' veut tour H6 tour D6 en fait
c'est vraiment
complexe B4
jouer
sur dame C4 il y a
tour4 mais peut-être dame prend à deux
he pourquoi pas soyons fous prenons tout
c'est ce qu'il veut he il veut tour4
dame à 2 c'est vrai qu' au bout d'un
moment ça va faire des pions surtout
qu'il a une sortie via H6 donc tour
il va peut-être faire tour H6 maintenant
c'est l'idée depuis tout à l'heure ouais
il veut tour
D6 c'est joli là comme parti comment il
sort cette
tourelle c'est bien
joué il prend pas le pion G4 àa parce
qu'il veut pas ouvrir la colonne h je
pense j'aurais pas pris non plus et en
plus c'est lui qui a peut-être l'option
de jouer h 4 un
jour c'est bien
joué c'est bien joué là ce que fait
Alireza et c'est vraiment
joli
tour 1 et là je pense qu'il va faire
tour D6 il va revenir et tour D8 parce
que tour D6 en fait sur dame 3 il y a
peut-être du dame pr c de échec hein et
s'il vient
E2 bah on peut faire peut-être dame
prend B4 au
final mais ça va faire deux pions de
plus et en plus ça va donner à la
majorité un vrai un vrai
avenir
lâche ça
fedos plus qu'une 06 pour le joueur je
crois qu' joue M S drapeau
slovè allez c'est bien la qui met la
pression au temp en plus de ça et on
arrive pas à finir côté côté Fed CF il
tente dame G5 c'est bien joué ça sur
dame C2 tour 2 dame G6 il veut échanger
aller prendre C7 et là leord dit donne
tour D5 comme gagnant mais c'est un coup
très difficile à avoir la ligne c'est
plutôt dame C2 dame G6 quand
même qui devrait rentrer dans une
position
nulle si la tour
D5 avec idée dame E3 dame prend B4 c'est
vraiment très très
fort tour D5 est globalement un coup
vraiment dur parce que ça coupe la
connexion de la dame avec le pion F7
aussi c'est pas un coup que j'aurais
joué et sur dame 3 dame B4 tour C7 je
sais pas ce que ve leur dit exactement
mais probablement tour D8 et tour D2 qui
va arriver c'est très difficile là c'est
très difficile tour des
5 extrêmement
difficile non j'aurais jamais eu tour
des5 même en partie
longue il fait dame prend C2 ouais c'est
ce que j'aurais joué aussi ça dame G6 et
ça va être nul mais c'est normal c'est
ce qu'on aurait tous
joué ça donne trop envie en fait enfin
trop envie pour C7 B6 on garde le pion
de plus mais en
final ça suffit pas mais c'est tellement
humain de rentrer
là-dedans
F5 est aussi une idée évidemment pour
aller prendre G4 en plus le pion G7 est
protégé par la tour ça c'est un truc
aussi qu'on voit tout de suite quand on
voit cette
variante alors il peut peut-être jouer
tour D8 tour B7 tour
D4 tour à7 tour E4 et tour B4 et rester
avec un pion de plus avec une position
quand même plus agréable avec peu de
temps
ouais c'est ce qu' va
faire t des5 ça coupé la connexion tout
à l'heure de la dame avec la case F7
c'était trop c'était pas humain là il va
faire tour D4 à mon avis tour D3 tour D4
qui revient à peu près au
même il peut rester avec un pion de plus
mais pas mieux
faire tour des 4 maintenant et sur tour
4 il peut même pas garder le pion de
plus c'est chum
ok mon pour C4 il va faire roi
G6
terrible G4
F5 il le fait pas
ouais il va y avoir à 5 là ah mais à 5
puis on prend tour C5 G6
attention quand même bon il va falloir
faire tour à 4 alors
ouais et tour G4 tour à 4 tour
OK et ça fait dro on pouvait pas faire
mieux ici allez avant de de ce quitir
les autres résultats nul de Carlsen qui
manquera un demi-point
ça joue
encore ça joue encore côté Martinez
Alcantara on va se mettre évidemment
côté côté noir côté péruvien s'il tient
la nulle avec les Noirs ici il lu
manquera plus qu'une nulle avec les
Blancs pour faire
mal
allez on espère fort on espère fort la
victoire de notre
chouchou et oui il a
gagné il a déjà gagné le le
tournoi en rapide il a éliminé tout le
monde et là il est peut-être en train de
sortir le vicechampion du monde il
faudra compter sur lui rosé Martinez
dans ce tournoi il est plus qu'à une
petite nulle là de d'une
qualification qui veut dire beaucoup je
pense que les parties vont rapidement
enchaîner rarement de pause entre la une
et la
c'est beau
ouais
ouis ça fait uni demi là il y a égalité
ça être la partie décisive pour
Maxime José Martinez
Alcantara pas on va avoir une autre vue
pendant pendant les
parties
on va avoir cette
vue on va voir cette magnifique
vue
il forir que Maxime fasse mal là avec
les pièces
noires en tout cas qui sauve le le
demi-point tiens j'en profite pour vous
demander pendant la pause est-ce que
vous avez
aimé la vidéo d'analyse que j'ai sorti
ce matin sur la chaîne facile l'analyse
light de la partie d'ikarou j'ai
l'impression que ça a quand même plu
globalement on attend là de toute façon
la partie je sais pas à quelle heure
exact sont peut-être vers enfin 18h58
quelque chose comme
ça allez ça part D4 cavalier F6 cavalier
F3 G6 Maxime qui va repartir avec la
même
variante donc en cas de match nul il y
aura un Armagedon dans ce dans ce
match c'est 3 il joue pas C4 euh ouais
c'est mou du short C3 normalement c'est
plutôt C4 le coup mais à 5 à 4 C6 il
veut jouer un
truc complètement
symétrique donc c'est 6 tour
ouais bon je sais pas c'est pas très
ambitieux j'avais jamais vu le le coup
enfin après c'est un peu comme les idées
D4 D5 cavalier F3 k F6
C3 l'idée c'est de pouvoir faire des
dames des dames des dames B3 parfois
mais là ça devait pas bien
marcher mon cavalier H4
fou6 prise prise prise prise prise
prise il a l'air de savoir ce qu'il fait
lazavic mais c'est pas mal ce qu'il
opien il s'est fait un petit
mur il s'est fait un petit
mur
fou G2 fou C4 et5
ouais ça casse pas TR PES un canard
quand même ce qu'il
fait ça casse quand même pas tris pattes
à un
canard il est solide mais c'est pas des
idées suffisantes normalement pour faire
V un
mvl après il est là tapis dans l'ombre
la zavi il attend la gaffe et il la
punira
il a un style qui ressemble en quelque
sorte à celui de Jo spem sont pas
forcément super entreprenant mais ils
ont ils ont des bons styles de blitzer
ils punissent les
erreurs Maxim qui
réfléchit ça fou des5 en fait en fait
qu'est-ce qu'on s'embête prendre des5 CD
cavalier F3 ouais bon enfin E6 qui B6
qui C4 enfin
oui non non F D5 c'est plus fort F C4
c'est le coup de l'ordi F D5 c'est le
coup humain F prend pu on prend cavalier
F3 E6 enfin merci mais tu as rien en
fait faut pas
exagérer il ne faut pas
exagérer
ouais bon ça c'est ouais mais non mais
je veux bien mais je veux bien que tu es
ton fou en F4 et que mais bon
ouis je peux pas croire que ce soit
mieux pour les blancs ça en
fait
ro
[Musique]
G2 il va mettre la dame en
ah
non est-ce qu'on peut faire cavalier F6
cavaler E5 cavalier
E4 fait Tor C8 il décide de ne pas
décider
ouais le fou C1 est plus actif que le
fou G7 on est sur un cas spécial où le
fou G7 est en muré et en 10 en muré dans
les
pions on va faire juste un un saut de
puce parce qu'on nous dit que notre
chouchou jospem est peut-être est
peut-être gagnant déjà contre Yan je
pense qu'il a fait juste imploser Yan
nepomashi nepomashi qui a complètement
implosé là avec les Noirs c'est pas
c'est pas la partie des des de joueurs
auquel vous avez les caméras mais a
peut-être déjà E5
y qui explose face à la puissance de
rosalcantara
Martinez ça nous met Gucci
ça peut-être en train de prendre une
sont le vicechampion du
monde et de se faire
exploser une dame 2 E5 de la part de
Maxime de cavalier prend E5 fou F4 oh là
qu'est-ce que c'est que ça Maxime qui
implose lui
aussi la doublette josp laavic et il y
aura peut-être demain une magnifique
demi-finale entre deux ça vaudra son
pesant de cacahuète si les deux se
qualifient
on suivra dans ces
CASL dans le loser bracket interne mvl
Nepi F F4 ça l'air pénible Maxime qui
all un peu trop vite avec ce sur F4
cavalier prend F3 a un vrai problème
c'est Dame pr pr PR8 et làdessus fou F8
le problème c'est pas roi pr F3 sur quoi
il y aurait dame C6 ça le problème c'est
qu' H6 F8
mat
donc aller prendre le
5 et fut F4
ouais et
F6 ah ouais non Maxime là qui a fait
nimpe il se fait écraser par
lazavic trop
dur
ah il est en train de se faire exploser
Yan et pourquoi aussi fan de de
Alcantara ben parce qu'en fait Alcantara
il y a deux
solutions solution numéro 1 c'est un
joueur qui en a rien à faire des échecs
et qui aurait le talent pour être top 10
mondial facile et en rapide il pourrait
même potentiellement être champion
champion du monde de rapide et de Blitz
mais il en a vraiment rien à faire donc
ça c'est option numéro 1 et c'est la
plus probable c'est juste il s'en fout
des échecs et il vient il clique comme
ça il défonce tout le monde partout
option numéro 2 il triche depuis des
années et il a déjà pris plusieurs
centaines de milliers de dollars sans
jamais se faire choper au quel cas c'est
aussi in génie parce que c'est pas comme
les joueurs du top mondial qui s
trichent sont quasiment indétectables
lui il est hyper
détectable donc en fait dans les deux
cas euh le gars est un génie c'est soit
c'est un génie des échecs dans le sens
où a rien à carrer et juste il gagne
comme ça de chez lui mais il s'en fout
il aurait pu vraiment être top top
mondial mais il en a rien à
faire donc génie ou deuxième cas de
figure c'est un joueur qui a zéro grosse
référence IRL et il réussi à tricher
depuis des années à gagner tout partout
tout le temps enfin plein de trucs sans
jamais se faire choper donc génie aussi
donc en fait il y a pas de cas où
Martinez Alcantara n'est pas un génie en
fait bon Maxime qui est en
difficulté ça le truc en fait c'est que
dans les deux cas de figure que tu
prennes l'un ou l'autre bah tu es obligé
de d'avoir du respect pour
lui les deux options en fait font de lui
un génie donc il y a pas
de
il y a pas de demi-mesure en
fait c'est que quel quel que soit le cas
de figure que tu prennes le gars est
fort c'est pour ça on espère qu'il aille
le plus loin possible parce qu'en fait
s'il gagne les tournois d'un tel niveau
c'est beau
aussi fait s gagne ce tour devant nepo
mvl Carlsen et C incroyable pour un
joueur qui joue quasiment en amateur
c'est même
fou et s'il réussit à cheat pour B tous
ces gensl avec autant d'argent en jeu
pendant autant de fois d'affilé c'est
aussi un génie donc en fait c'est enin
dans tous les cas c'est
beau TR de traiter génie de la triche ou
génie du jeu TR de traiter génie s'il
triche ben il y a plein d'escroc géniaux
je sais pas comment
dire lesescrerie c'est un
Artin ah c'est joli là sur cavalier D2
il y a un piégeos il y a tour prend des4
qui passe puis on prend des qu cavalier
E3 échec et dame prend
C2 très bien joué
Maxime là qui a très très bien joué la
série de coup
ouis c'est bien là ce que fait Maxime il
est complètement revenu dans la
game cavalier
D6 Maxime là qui est bien revenu dans la
game pendant qu'on parlait de notre
chouchou
dame
D3 il va faire cavalier F5 là Maxime je
pense et cavalier D2 ah il a pas le
temps de cavalier prendre
des4
tour
1 cavalier F5 et là l'ordi donne un coup
très fort que j'avais donc complètement
trouvable c'est FO a
7 et j'avais c'était mon coup main parce
que sur B6 d' prend des5 prise D5 prise
D5 le fou il va
sortir conttear j'espère qu'il termine
qu'il fasse le taf
la zavi qui est mal au
temps mais la partie est difficile
à
un CADR il a FO 6 x 7 ouais j'avais
aussi hein c'est complètement trouvable
comme
coup
là Maxime va être dans le
dur c'est très bien joué et est-ce qu'on
a tour D8 où il y a dame prend
E4 pision prend tour D8 3 F7 je regarde
jette un œil cavalier D4 on a du dame C7
ouais ok ça
passe
donc B6 adame prend D5 et tour A8 il a
le temps de faire cavalier D4 pour
échanger les pièces et remettre le fou
en D4 ouais là maxime est vraiment très
mal
maintenant il est peut-être en train de
se faire la zavi
kifier
c'est
fort alors que le chouchou échange
tout il est peut-être en train de se
griser le chouchou attention le
chouchou faut réussir à faire
nul donc tour à 8 joué par Maxim et là
cavalier D4 serait
fort
ouais il a trouvé cavalier D4 pardon
j'ai switché de partie une petite
seconde mais ouais là Maxime va c'est
terrible lazavi a très très bien joué
il a été il a vraiment nettement dominé
Maxime dans cette partie
stratégiquement et tactiquement aussi
ouais c'est propre parce que maintenant
Maxime il est pieds et points liés à ce
pion et ça va être très très difficile
de faire quelque chose dame F3 était
peut-être un coup un tout petit peu à
côté alors pourquoi un tout petit peu à
côté parce que ça enlève de la pression
sur le pion
D5 mais bon ça reste très bien quand
même parce qu'il veut tour D3 tour D1 ah
Maxime qui fait F5 ah c'est tellement
bien joué F5 en coup de défense en fait
il veut fou prend G7 3 prend G7 tour
tour AD1 et tour E5 pour venir blinder
le pion latéralement c'est très très
très très très bien joué de la part de
Maxime ça et ça souligne la lenteur de
dame F3 ça permet à Maxime de mettre en
place ce
setup ah la zavi qui a jou un petit coup
à côté Maxime qui en profite et
maintenant il peut peut-être tout trquer
et mettre la tour en E4 ah il va rester
moins bien quand
même mais il a joué quelques coups à
côté on va voir le chouchou allez le
chouchou qui est peut-être bien là ah le
chouchou qui est très très bien le
chouchou qui est en train d'être
dominant qui est en train d'éliminer Yan
pomashi allez Maxime qui a trouvé la
variante avec prise des4 prise D4 et
tour4 alle sur dame sur dame D3 il va
échanger la finale de dame doit être nul
il va mettre la dame en E6 et il va
jouer pour dame4 Maxime qui va aller
chercher les l'armagedon
[Musique]
probablement il peut jouer B6 ou
B5 je pense qu' jouer B5 c'est plus ce
sty maximb dame prend B6 c'est B6 B5 je
pensais plus
B5 attende l'ORD la donne gagnant ah il
peut prendre tour D1 et prise C5 nickel
le
chouchou elle fait du bien cette
victoire là qui se qui se matérialise
contre
y H4 il va jouer H5 non et c'est nul nul
signé Maxime qui a tenu allez on va voir
le
chouchou le chouchou qui vient de jouer
qui prend des6 sur dame prend des6 a
tour D1 dame C7 F prend C5 et fou des6 F
fend B8 let's
go pay buraliste
que oui quel dommage qu'on puisse pas
faire faire des des paris quand même sur
les parties d'échec parce que ils
auraient mis Martinez Alcantara à 4 ou 5
comme côte j'aurais fait très très mal
he parce que pour moi c'était énorme
favori du match contre Yan aïe aïe AE a
AE AE AE c'est pas de bol
ça qu'on puisse pas gumbleall là-dessus
pas de bol pour le streamer français qui
avait ouais là j'avais complètement dans
le Range là c'était facile pour
moi
sous-estimé
Yan qui est en train d'imploser contre
le
chouchou enchr ouais je crois que c'est
les enchères à fond là
magnifique le chouchou le chouchou le
chouchou bam tour
des1
désolé on était pris par le chouchou
quoi et alira il a quelle pièce il a les
blancs il là les blanc il a plutôt une
bonne
position ses cavaliers sont forts il a
une meilleure
structure
c'est fort et le chouchou est-ce que
c'est fini
il est en train de l'exploser Yan se
fait exploser il se fait
ratioiserirea qui a l'avantage il veut
rentrer en B6 gagner le à
6 il y a un et demi 1 et demi là les
scores sont pas à
jour Mathieu qui a la cam les deux
rigolent tu veux dire le chouchou et
Yan je go stream international les rêv
de jospem je comprends pas le délire tu
qu'il regarde pas la game de
jospem fou G7 tour
B6 les champion du monde du 18 c'est pas
une ref pour Alcantara c'est pas de
talon un amateur non plus ah si c'est
une ref hein mais
il y a une DIF entre champion du monde
junior et et jouer top 5
mondial régulièrement mais après comme
je disais
c'est il y a vraiment deux possibilités
avec lui et il y a vraiment dans le
Range comme il a dit qu'il voulait
arrêter les échecs l'an prochain et tout
la possibilité qu'il aime genre juste
pas les échecs qu' fasse juste ça pour
l'argent et qu'il en est vraiment
RAF de de de jouer en compète hein c'est
possible qu'il ait pas du tout envie et
qu'en fait il a un talent de fou et
qu'il aurait pu être champion du monde
ou en tout cas top 15 20 mondial s'il
s'il avait voulu mais just en a vraiment
rien à [__] pe ce qu'il aime pas en
fait du tout et que il est juste content
de de jouer de chez lui tranquille ou
quoi c'est complètement possible hein
c'est il y a pas de mais du coup c'est
pour ça que je dans les deux cas de
Figur il y a pas qure Figur où c'est pas
où c'est pas intéressant en
fait
mais donc tour à 5 là le coup très fort
pour la turbine c'est très beau parce
que ça vient taper sur la 5e rangée
parce que si triche c'est beau aussi
enfin je sais pas comment dire en fait
et jusqu'à preuve du contraire c'est
juste c'est pas lui de prouver qu'il
joue
honnêtement donc tour à
c'est fou comme tu as radicalement
changé ta vision sur depuis la rencontre
avec crramic pas du
tout absolument rien
changer d'ailleurs quand on a fait
l'interview on a redonné notre vision
des choses avec Maxime qui est la même
depuis des
années
donc est-ce qu'il va le
faire il fait ça
F3
ça va wi
easy Caval C3 prend E6 et il va ça va
wiasy je vous dis ça mais c'est pas tout
à fait le cas cavalier C3 t prend6
prend6 ah il y a cavalier prend des4
c'est la pointe qui vu alza t prend des4
cavalier prend C3 prend C4 cavalier
E4 et du coup il fait cavalier C tour
prend6 intermédiaire il va jouer
cavalier prend6 c'est sûr tour prend D3
et cavalier
D2 al qui va probablement se qualifier
mais attention il est encore là fedos
fedos et de platine cavalier C5 il a
encore du D3
fedos cavalier
D2
cavalier B3 maintenant allez on ferme la
puerta allez k B3 c'est le joli coup ça
à trouveré il le trouve
Alireza parfait tour C5 maintenant pour
aller bouffer le pion parfait alza qui
fait le boulot là ah si on fait tomber
le pion G5 on fait tomber le socle en
plus H2 on se cache et T G5 on va tout
couvrir et envoyer le pion Adam allez
comme Damian P ce soir contre les
handais il faut qu'il file ce pion allez
BIM on envoie pousse ah j'espère qu'il a
le pouce dans le Range quand
même
pousse il faut qu'il pousse il faut
qu'il Pousse Pousse Pousse Pousse Pousse
il faut qu'il réussisse à pousser là il
va revenir en F5 avec son cheval allez
il pousse
pousse allez on vient H2 avec le roi
cavalier F4 tour G5 on est de retour oh
là il part en H4 il me fait peur
ouis il me fait peur là
il me fait super peur mais allez C6 non
il fait tour ici ve en fait il veut
ramener le roi en G5 il veut monter vers
h6 il me fait hyper peur il me fait
hyper peur alirea mais là ça va il a
l'air d'être sous contrôle oh là là là
là là c'est qu'est-ce qu'il fait où il
va où tu vas là-bas tout seul dans le
noir comment il s'est retrouvé dans un
réseau là-bas au lieu juste de pousser
mais il est hyper mal il va perdre en
fait il a deux doigts de perdre Ali
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'il a fait il
avait la tour en G4 le r H2 il était
complètement
safe et il s'est embarqué dans un
truc au lieu de
pousser oh il a fait n'importe
quoi allez je sais cavalier C4
C6 ah il a vraiment fait n là pour le
coup il a pas cavalier C5 aurait tour F7
ah tour F7 a prise et cavalier prend
des3 ça
va c'est
bouillant cavalier A6 cavalier
C je crois je crois qu'il va perdre il y
a tour7 éche prend dame c'est trop ce
qu'il a
fait c'est trop al éliminé
incroyable ce qu'il a raté
Alireza comment il a joué n'importe
comment pourquoi pas ro H2 cavalier F4
et juste sur G5 tour 2 et tu
pousses pourquoi tu pousses pas en
fait pourquoi tu pousses pas oh il a
trollé Ali le
match
attend les caméras sont mal mises mais
je suis au
courant ça va être le seul armagadon
celui de
Maxime oh là là là là là là il a fait
n'importe quoi liarza il a complètement
troll ah il a troll d'un puissance
ça a
dégoûté ah il a vraiment il a monté son
roi c'était n'importe
quoi ah le
sam
ah le
j'ai un peu le seum
là attendez on va récupérer les cames
des joueurs qui sont recadrer
maintenant
terrible
terrible al resa là c'est fou ce qu'il a
fait c'est vraiment
fou qu'en plus il a raté celle avec les
Blancs
il a raté celleel en fait il a raté de
deux trucs hyper facile il a fait Z0 sur
de dans deux positions complètement
gagnantes TW de
Yan il a fait quoi il doit être dégoûté
y Maxime qui va voir les noirs
Yan il doit avoir un se
monumental non mon avis c'est voui et
ouais il suit du chouchou
hein
c'estécrit comment la
cryptonite
attendez he je cherche un
truc je crois que j'ai trouvé comment ça
s'écrivait
alle il faut que
[Musique]
Maxime fasse le
taf je crois qu'il aura les noirs on va
on vérifiera
on ne sait pas qu' a le le temps qu'il
aura mais bon belle victoire du
chouchou ça devrait reprendre dans 3
minutes ah ils sont très heureux sur ch
chesscam Espagne de cette
victoire et donc all demain qui
affrontera West Lau dans le loser
bracket alors que la partie commence ah
non pas du
tout céit la game du chouchou qui
repartait non c'est Maxime qui aura les
blancs
ça va bientôt
repartir
attz ça va
on attend on
attend on attend le début de la
game c'est beau quoi j SP est très
heureux sur son
Twitter il dit qu'il est pas content des
accusations constantes de triche je vais
lui mettre un
likein allez ça va
partir il a raison jospem je suis
d'accord avec
lui
bon on
attend
allez c'est parti Maxime qui ouvre par
au 4 il aura 10 minutes contre 936 et il
joue une une Anglaise allez ça part
fort ça fait un genre de sicilienne à à
couleur inversée dame C2 qui D4 dame4 il
touche le cavalier cavalier prend F3 il
va jouer quoi Maxime il va jouer fou
prend et il tape 5 et il tape des 5
prise prise oh il a l'air de connaître
Maxime ou alors il est en pur bluff bon
il est en P bluff en fait il est
complètement P bluff là il peut pas
connaître aussi loin mais il va jouer à
5 ouais s'il est en P bluff il envoie à
5 tempo je pense comme ça sur B6 il a a
6 et sur fou D7 il fera dame C4 il fait
D4 dame
F6
il joue quoi il joue quoi max je crois
qu'il a complètement raté son ouverture
il a complètement raté l'ouverture
Maxime il a tout c
tempo j'ai l'impression qu'il a fait
n dame
D3 cro va mettre la tour en
D1
B6 c'est à 5 allez il faut vraiment
faire à 5 là côté Maxime pour éviter de
se faire
fixer puis on prend puis on prend il
joue tout tempo lazavi qu'il en a rien à
faire et il fait zéro
erreur il est beaucoup trop
solide
W
ouais il faut tenter peut-être d prend
B5 prend F6
il s'est fait complètement aniler Maxime
je sais pas trop ce qui s'est passé mais
c'est comme s'il avait plus le le
mojo et si Maxime fait nul il per là
c'est l'armadon
ouais il s'est fait il s'est fait
complètement éteindre là il a même pas
eu de
partie laavi a été beaucoup trop
fort les deux Français qui vont se
retrouver dans le loser
bracket là il y a pas un dame B5 qui
fonctionne pour menacer fou G5 a dame G6
seul coup mais il y a dame G6 qui
passe il a du bol je suis pas sûr qu'il
ait tout vu la zavic mais ouais il est
facile Maxime va échanger les dames et
juste faire nul il accepte son
infériorité
Maxime c'était trop fort aujourd'hui
côté bélorusse Maxime qui a aucune
chance bizarre cette
partie
ouais il est dépité ouais il s puis en
plus il se prend tout
tempo il va être dans le loser braquet
contre Yan
nepomiashi
ouis c'est
terrible j'ai jamais entendu parler de
ce mec il a dé truc carou et mvl c'est
potentiel champion du monde
euh non pas du tout il a genre 18 ans il
est 25
mais il a été assez mauvais au grand
Suisse pour son âge donc
non
ok il va falloir jouer pour tour D2 fou
D4 F3 E4 c'est la seule chance pour
essayer quelque chose mais normalement
il va jamais y arriver
ou c'est terrible
bon mais demain on aura quand même des
beaux matchs à suivre puisqu'on
aura on aura du mvl et
du et du alza dans le loser bracket et
on repassera quand même après avec un
super lazavic jospem
demain dans le winner bracket et le
vainqueur de ce match là qui sera opposé
à Carlsen
après
fouass mvl nepo wi car j laavic
ouais il va tenter ça Maxime de donner
la cale
ouais ça va faire fa nul Maxime qui a
rien pu faire
éteint peut même pas essayer en fait
Maxime il va proposer nul
et
et quit cette
partie
il rend le pion c'est bien joué mais si
Maxime le prend c'est nul facile
ouais bon c'est
pas
Maxim qui tente on sait pas trop quoi
mais qui le
tente VO G5 il va abandonner je crois
qu'il a même plus envie de jouer en fait
je connais Maxime là quand il joue les
coups comme ça tout tempo c'est qu'il
est
dégoûté allez hop terminado bah merci
d'avoir suivi on va se retrouver demain
donc pour de superbes matchs d'abord le
loser
bracket en quelque sorte en hors d'œuvre
et ensuite le magnifique lazavic Jos
spem donc ne
rater surtout pas ça Maxime qui s'est
déco instant oua bon il était dégoûté là
Maxime et on se retrouve donc demain
merci à tous ciao ciao ciao à demain
bonne bonne fin de
soirée quel est le meilleur moyen de
suivre n'importe quel événement échiquen
Surpat du monde au tournoi des candidats
en passant par le speed chess ou les
title today
chess.com/evenents de tous les plus
grands tournois d'échec qui se déroulent
en présentiel ou en ligne vivez et
comprenez en direct les parties des
meilleurs joueurs de la planète avec les
commentaires en français de nos experts
notre moteur d'analyse l'explorateur
d'ouverture et les tables bases trouver
toutes les infos essentielles comme le
programme les horaires des rondes les
prix les résultats les contrerendus
quotidien les des joueurs les règles des
partage et plus encore vous pouvez même
participer à la compétition en
pronostiquant les résultats tenter de
gagner des abonnements premium alors
rendez-vous dès maintenant sur
chess.com/events aussi bien sur le site
internet ou sur nos applications iOS et
Android pour vivre votre passion comme
nul par
aille